if you're like me you're probably always
in front of your screens have you ever
stopped to think about your digital
footprint all of the text messages
emails social media posts
my question is
what happens to all of this data
after you die
i'm going to explore this emerging space
called the digital afterlife from three
different edges what happens to your
data how it can take on a life of its
own and what it means to be digitally
immortal
[Music]
in 2019 twitter announced that it was
going to start deleting accounts of
inactive users and their reasoning made
a lot of sense accounts of inactive
users are unable to agree to updated
policy terms but their announcement
sparked a fury of backlash as one
article stated and meant that they might
be losing a digital remnant of loved
ones
but it shows that someone's digital
identity can still be meaningful even
after they've passed away
as we live more of our lives online
these digital archaeological sites that
we leave behind will only expand we'll
be able to see how you laid in on
certain cultural moments like whether
the dress was blue or gold and sync or
bsb or if you heard yanny or laurel
really eerie it's definitely ural by the
way
taking care of your online affairs
before you pass away isn't just about
passing down digital remnants to your
great great grandchildren it's also
about protecting your digital identity
from hackers and scammers who have been
known to impersonate and target the
accounts of deceased users so how should
we deal with all this we estimate to be
over 30 million dead people on facebook
which is just mind-blowing because they
all send birthday reminders they're on
linkedin they're sending work
anniversaries so it's a disgrace really
that's ricard ceo of good trust a leader
in the death tech industry the company
gathers your data and preserves it after
you die
we did a survey and it turns out that
some 90
of people here in the us have no plans
whatsoever what happens to the stuff so
it will just remain there but the
problem is of course if you had
priceless photos in your icloud account
your loved ones may not find them if you
had that bitcoin somewhere hidden away
priceless sort of memories and monetary
assets will be lost forever who owns
that data do the tech company still own
it yeah i would argue that some tech
companies probably think that they own
it but i would argue that they don't if
you think about google facebook apple
if you contact them saying hey my wife
passed away and then they're wondering
who are you again you say your husband
but are you really entitled to
inherit your wife so it's a very
complicated process and that's one of
the things that we're trying to do
at scale because if you have to do this
with 20 sites it becomes a very
laborious task we want to make sure that
long after you're gone you will have a
representation where people can see you
remember you and potentially also
interact with you in a way that you'd
think be good for
for who you are whether you want to
protect your data from hackers or
preserve it for loved ones companies
like good trust can help you get your
digital footprint in order but it turns
out this data you leave behind might one
day take on a life of its own with
advances in technology it's possible to
interact with the deceased and expect a
reply back
ai chatbots which we interact with all
the time in customer service inquiries
are trained by providing the ai with
examples of the type and style of
language you want it to learn from and
eventually replicate and the ai that
powers these chat bots is getting really
really good
joshua barbeau is a freelance writer
from canada and last year he went viral
after sharing his story about how he
digitally resurrected his ex-fiancee
using a chat bot
and he did this by training it on her
old text and facebook messages
and he said that there were elements of
the conversation that truly reminded him
of her and that the chatbot had given
him permission to move on with his life
in small ways but it makes me wonder
what are the implications of digital
resurrections and chat bots on the
grieving process
i mean in some cases it seems to help
but where's the line
when we think about losing people or
things things that are important to us
right if we have access to those things
we're going to want to do that over and
over again this is dr liz toliver she's
a long-term grief counselor and she's
been researching ai and its effects on
grief if we perhaps are prolonging or
continuing to be able to have access to
these individuals through ai is it
prolonging our pain is it prolonging our
struggle and i think the risk in that
when we think about addiction is that
then addiction
impedes our ability to stay in the
present moment and what could be the
potential societal implications of a
world where we don't think we fully die
or we at least think we can continue to
interact with loved ones my school of
thought and my
framework and scaffolding is really
allowing each individual to have their
own experience and bringing into the
room with them their world view and a
lot of that comes from their culture and
the implications for that could be that
a lot of those traditions are lost i
also think that we are taking away or
minimizing the value in those traditions
that cultures have passed down for
hundreds and possibly thousands of years
so it's important to consider these
long-term cultural effects technology is
extending the limits of our lifetime but
to live on through a chat bot might
cause more harm than good the thing
about chat bots and avatars is that at
the end of the day we know those aren't
the thoughts and words of deceased loved
ones they're an ai's best prediction at
what the deceased might say
unless of course it could somehow tap
into our brains
or at least the contents in it
[Music]
a memory engram is the physical
representation of a memory the
collection of cells that store a memory
and thanks to advances in technology we
can now see memory engrams
the green stain in this photo it's
actually long-term fear memories
while most of the research on memories
is grounded in finding solutions for
brain disorders such as alzheimer's or
depression there's a lot of implications
on the digital afterlife if we can see
memories can we manipulate them and even
preserve them after we die
you know the idea of uploading memories
to
the cloud uh for example
is really popular culture right now tv
shows like upload or westworld really
speaks to this and futurists like ray
kurzweil has championed this idea for
some time and he even suggests that by
that we'll be able to do this
this is dr joshua serenana a
neuroscientist who explores how
technology can let us see and manipulate
memories
we can actually use fmri data or
functional mri data to reconstruct
memories using brain activity uh
specifically using ai technologies which
interprets this brain activity to
reconstruct images even videos now the
resolution is quite low but the
technology is getting better and better
so with respect to memories more
specifically
i think to grasp the significance of
being able to store and manipulate
memories and the impact that could have
on the digital afterlife we would have
to understand the role that memories
play and shaping our identities and our
realities as a neuroscientist
how much would you say of who we are
is based on our memories
memory memories literally shape our
identities our experiences alter the
connections between the neurons and our
brain and they shape the brain and mind
in this way and with regard to our
reality in the present moment you're
constantly looking back to the past in
order to understand the future
so our memories literally shape our
brains and our minds and therefore our
identities and being able to upload them
really starts the conversation of
digital immortality
but i think there's still one more piece
to the puzzle
the thing that makes us who we are
our consciousness
i wanted to talk to dr michael graziano
because he's actively studying the brain
basis of consciousness and the potential
of uploading it
the brain is a functioning machine it's
information that's moving in very
specific ways and that's exactly what
artificial neural networks do like
everything around us your cell phone
search engines and self-driving cars
they all operate on this mimic of
biology and so the thing is to get
that kind of machinery to build into it
the pattern of connectivity from an
actual person
so uploading our brain would essentially
be the ultimate digital afterlife yes
then there's in the end two of you in a
way compared to a y where the stock of
the y is you from the time you're born
up to the point where your brain gets
scanned and then at that point the y
branches and one half of it is the
biological you and the other half is
this digital you that thinks it's you
wakes up in some simulated digital world
and says to itself hey it worked and the
other one the biologically you wakes up
and says um didn't help me i'm still
gonna die so which is the real you i
think they both are it's the watershed
moment in our species is the moment that
we
understand consciousness well enough to
engineer it and upload it we change
fundamentally who and what we are and
that's fraught with all kinds of you
know both good and bad consequences one
thing we've been noticing as we've been
studying this the digital afterlife as a
space is who's in the room while it's
being built is really important
who's making these decisions is it
equitable how do we know everybody can
access it to be a part of the future
that we actually want to live in that's
right i do not imagine it being
equitable and so you're going to have a
situation where you're going to have a
limited resource that has to be doled
out so the potential for abuse is
relatively huge but my own work is much
more on the topic of insight it
basically says mind uploading is
possible but it doesn't tell you how to
do it right i think it's inevitable
that's going to happen anyway it's just
that's people do that and when you see
industries like space evolving we talk
about terraforming mars or building
environments that can house humans from
your perspective why not just house the
mind yes people have space wrong the
star treks and the star wars is and the
light speed are faster than light speed
travel like that's not going to happen
but if you don't need to build an
environment to house the human body all
you need is to build a platform to house
the human mind that's the future of
space trail if you could give one piece
of advice to tech companies who are
working to solve this problem who are
waiting for your research so they can go
make a product with it what would that
piece of advice be for mind uploading i
don't know what advice i would give
except it's worthwhile thinking it
through ahead of time rather than
waiting until it's here and then trying
to clean up the mess
after it happens
the digital afterlife is a spectrum from
the photos that we share and the emails
that we send to the potential of
uploading consciousness
technology has always brought about
profound change
combining the brain power of the living
and the dead could take us to new
heights and there's something kind of
beautiful and knowing that death may not
have to stay so final but there's also
something kind of beautiful and knowing
that even with the perfect brain
simulator and the avatars and all of the
technology it's still not you whatever
makes you human and uniquely you
stays
at least for now
[Music]